this morning as the race to vaccinate
people picks up around the world the
scramble for vaccine supplies is
becoming heated
the european union backed down last
night from a major diplomatic incident
with the uk
over exports of the vaccine at the same
time the world health organization is
again warning about the dangers of what
it calls
vaccine nationalism mts tayab
is in our london bureau this morning mts
good morning
michelle good morning to you well there
is a very big fight brewing here
on this side of the pond with britain
and the european union
at each other's throats over whose
orders of vaccines
should be honored first as manufacturers
desperately struggle
to keep up if all politics is local
then the european union is picking a
fight with its closest
and most complicated neighbor splashed
across the front pages of britain's
newspapers are screeching headlines
accusing the eu
of putting the united kingdom's vaccine
supply at risk
it follows the now backtracked threat
from the eu
it would start to restrict exports of
coronavirus shots
to northern ireland the war of words
boiled over after the british swedish
firm astrazeneca said it can only
deliver a fraction of the hundreds of
millions of vaccine doses
it promised to both the eu and britain
because of production delays but with
both sides demanding their pledges be
met first
the world health organization has shot
back with a stark warning
vaccine nationalism might serve
short-term political goals
but it's ultimately short-sighted and
self-defeating we will not
end the pandemic anywhere until we end
it
everywhere if the eu's battle with
vaccine manufacturers over delivery
shortfalls continues
it could affect up to 100 nations
including
the u.s complicating matters the eu is
also in dispute with pfizer over the
late provision of its vaccine
the block says agreements must be met
europe invested
billions to help develop the world's
first covet 19 vaccines
and now the companies must deliver
they must honor their obligations
the coronavirus is continuing to cause
misery around the world
new more infectious strains of the virus
from britain brazil and south africa
are being found in several other nations
making the already approved inoculations
needed now
more than ever now if this increasingly
bitter battle over vaccine is a sign of
things to come
inoculating the rest of the world from
covet 19
will be an even more herculean task than
ever anticipated dana let's just hope
everyone's up for it mts thank you